[Musique]
ce jeudi 19 mars cyrille melchior
président du département s'est rendue au
foyer d'accueil médicalisé thalys
vertain qui accueille trente résidants
porteurs de handicaps sévères
ce foyer d'accueil médicalisé offre
depuis peu un nouveau cadre de vie à ses
occupants grâce à une série de travaux
qui ont débuté ces dernières semaines
la priorité a été donnée à la réfection
des 32 chambres 16 douchez 32 sanitaire
équipant l'établissement le département
effectivement a été alertée par une
situation que je juge intolérables
d'accueil des personnes en difficulté
dans cet établissement est bien
évidemment nous avons demandé à nos
services de réagir rapidement pour que
la structure soit améliorée que les
chambres soit revue de façon à ce
qu'elle soit accueillante que tout ce
qui touche aux sanitaires brasse
sécurité à l'hygiène de ces personnes et
biens soient améliorées j'ai demandé à
ce que ces travaux soit menée le plus
rapidement possible et aujourd'hui donc
je suis venu avec bien évidemment les
services du département accueillis par
l'établissement de façon à voir comment
ces travaux ont été réalisés et je suis
satisfait du chantier se poursuivra
jusqu'en septembre 2022 le département a
également accordé une enveloppe
budgétaire à l'embellissement des
extérieurs pour les espaces de loisirs
et de promenade
[Musique]